voi sapete chi è questa persona si no
questa persona dell'enar demi moore che
elevate e poi vai e spock brava quelli
del dottor spock
probabilmente nessuno di voi aveva
riconosciuto forse solo lei quando però
vi ho detto che il dottor spock che è
che conosce il dottor spock un sacco di
persone
lui è un attore un artista una persona
che non è un lavoro vero fare l'artista
non è proprio una cosa cioè ma che ci
paga il mutuo di casa invece un marmo
lavoro vero è un lavoro dove si è
laureato se l'ingegnere 6 medico 6
avvocato
sapete chi è questa persona lei ha un
lavoro vero
lei è un ex pilota è un pilota militare
un astronauta e samantha cristoforetti
conosce cinque lingue due lauree in
questo momento in orbita e il problema
con leonard che quello di prima e che
l'anno scorso è morto per cui quello che
è successo e che lei in orbita ha fatto
questo gesto che il saluto di star trek
e ha indossato la maglietta in star trek
ed effettivamente se provo ci pensate
bene lei in orbita perché come voi è
stata ispirata dal film di star trek per
esempio voi sarete stati ispirati da un
altro libro da un'altra cosa qualsiasi
altra roba che ha scritto un sognatore e
un sacco di gente si è sbattuta per
costruire l'astronave su cui a lei
adesso per quali la stazione spaziale e
fisicamente in orbita è quella lì è
veramente la curvatura della terra
lei probabilmente astronauta perché
voleva fare come star trek è andata
nello spazio voleva esplorare lo spazio
come voi avrebbe fatto le volte le
vostre scelte dopo che avete visto un
film da letto un libro ed è fatto
qualcosa che vi ha ispirato per cui è
vero che gli ingegneri o quella gente lì
sono importanti hanno un lavoro serio ma
anche i sognatori anche quelli che
inventano cose pur non facendo che
fisicamente sono importanti che sono
loro che ispirano il futuro
e poi altrettanto importante c'è un
sacco di gente che il futuro la inventa
per davvero
per cui io faccio computer grafica se
volessi fare medicina il mio problema
sarebbe che ha un sacco di anni di
storia
tantissimi un sacco di libri un sacco di
cose se volessi fare architettura un
altro lavoro serio non è che mi fa tanto
meglio perché anche lì ho un sacco di
anni da studiare
se volessi fare ingegneria wow ancora
anche l'ingegnere forse ancora peggio
fotografia mi va un po meglio perché
fotografia o tipo 2 300 anni quindi sono
aveva abbastanza bene
se voglio fare invece computer grafica
ieri perché la computer grafica
praticamente nata ieri quindi si studia
veramente poco fatto computer grafica
all'inizio all'inizio la forma di fifa
computer grafica è questa perché quando
una decina faccio computer grafica la
seconda domanda che ti viene detta
centro problema world nei sistemi no
glielo so usare word impossibile tu sei
un genio
no perché la gente ha in mente quella
roba lì nagy che la gente ha in mente
quello lì dietro al computer che fa
delle cose incredibili in uno scantinato
non parla con nessuno nessuno sa cosa fa
quella persona no poi a un certo punto
però è uscito questo film al cinema che
l'hanno vista probabilmente sette
persone in sala qualcuno l'ha visto e
sono tutte presenti quindi un momento
storico è un momento storico
questo film era la prima volta al mondo
in cui si usava la computer grafica e la
usava degli artisti per fare delle cose
che prima faceva soltanto ingegneri o
altra gente cervellona no però la gente
non aveva capito bene allora ci ha
pensato la pixar e ha fatto questo che è
che ha visto toy story
da lì si è capito praticamente che la
computer grafica non solo poteva fare
soldi ma poteva raccontare un sacco di
storie della tecnologia non era più così
complicata e che gli artisti finalmente
potevano usare la computer grafica al
pari di una penna quindi da quel punto
che adesso facciamo un piccolo corso di
computer grafica quello che fa un
artista di computer graphic art
normalmente aprire il suo computer
aprile ma ieri un software che come gli
altri ma 3d studio max rivolgeva
schiaccia un bottone con scritto creata
dopo su questo bottone schiaccia polygon
cube e nuovi vertici anche sono comandi
veri esistono all'interno del software
lo rifà un milione di volte tutto il
giorno fa questa cosa e ora fino a
thiene questo finco lo rifà ancora un
sacco di volte per tutto il giorno
magari anche un paio di settimane e alla
fine
voi vedete questo perché realizza
l'astronave di star trek e nei film li
realizzano così muovendo i vertici ma la
cosa più interessante che c'è un sacco
di gente che qui è presente anche al che
studia le onde gravitazionali buchi neri
i motori a curvatura al teletrasporto
vuole andare su marte proprio perché è
stata ispirata da questa cosa qua perché
un sognatore ha realizzato questo film
voi siete già andati su marte avete già
visto de march hanno un sacco di film
che vi hanno già descritto marte non ci
sta e già stati tutte le missioni che
adesso andranno su marte per voi sarà
bab al normale
andiamo su marte per far questo vedete
sono un sacco di film che vi ispirano
continuamente ogni giorno un sacco di
sognatori un sacco di gente lavora delle
cose che probabilmente altre persone
realizzeranno ok io la fortuna di
lavorare una scuola dove coltiviamo un
sacco di questi sognatori oltre
insegnargli la computer grafica per
spiegarglielo chiaramente che tutto è
possibile quello che facciamo li
portiamo lì nel niente nel deserto del
tra lo utah è la california
prendiamo dei ragazzi che hanno più o
meno tra i venti venticinque anni dopo
avergli fatto un corso in computer
grafica li abbandoniamo e lì in mezzo
con 10 gip diciamo fatto che vuoi
tutto è possibile vuoi andare da qualche
parte facce può andare lì in mezzo vai
vuoi andare a vedere con certe macchine
cosa c'è nel niente
vuoi farlo far parte in rai perché lo
puoi fare è possibile sia adesso
prendessi una bacchetta magica e vi
riportasse indietro magari qualcuno di
voi ha più di 40 anni crede io 40 anni
per cui si potessero dare una bacchetta
magica magica rimettermi a 15 anni
se io volessi fare l'astronauta
probabilmente adesso sarà in orbita
sicuro al cento per cento chiede di voi
è convinto che se gli mettono lo rimetto
a 15 anni cambia drasticamente la
propria vita solo io 2
vabbè solo a noi quattro tutti gli altri
avete avuto la vita perfetta fantastico
quello dobbiamo spiegare ragazzi e
questa cosa renderli consapevoli non ha
40 anni del fatto che puoi cambiare la
vita ma farlo adesso cioè in questo
istante esatto spiegargli che tutto è
possibile
noi per esempio quando questo panorama
incredibile cosa che notata in questo
panorama incredibile quella stella
quella non è una stella
questa fotografia qui l'ha fatta
curiosity su marte quelle marte e quella
stella quel pixel che cela in mezzo alla
terra
noi siamo su quel pixel qui tutti i
casini che fate io faccio così perché
non vi vedo tutti i casini che fate le
guerre i problemi il fatto che petrolio
mille casi è quello da marte è
incredibile tutto si ridimensiona perché
marte il nostro dc smart è veramente
dietro l'angolo non è un problema
arrivare su un problema arrivare su
alpha centauri di andare in altre
galassie c'è un sacco di roba e mezzo
possiamo scoprire un sacco di cose
incredibili fittissime tifa computer
grafica c'è già stato
avete già visto star trek tutte quelle
robe lì no dovrebbe vederlo anche la
gente normale perché quando vi rendete
conto che siete su quel pixel
potete essere solo due cose o sognatori
e inventato il futuro può essere
ispirati da un sognatore lo create
veramente il futuro se siete in mezzo
state perdendo tempo
cosa